hello and welcome to this video mr.
wanna gasps okay does he have something
new for us in store only play as usual
Queens gambit with night bd7 I mean
nothing ever happens we'll see okay i'll
go 83 now in turn I'm just well and as
you have seen I've changed my strategy
here a little bit against him I'm just
playing along this kind of non lines and
I'm okay with it I just make drawers
okay um let's see them Queen d2 and
probably quite sure babe did I lose a
temp or somewhere else with it looks
already rather comfortable for black I
mean I play that line with the black as
well so I kind of wonder probably
probably it's it's okay how I how I
played it
ok I think I can just take here right I
just play quick not lose our time and
very good more I'm a little bit quicker
on the open files but it shouldn't
shouldn't be anything serious ok can I
get some kind of initiative Queenie form
may be attacking that porn I mean
initiative as a strong good let's make a
little bit of lift here for the king and
can I do something here um she's going
rube t8 next I what is he doing
now I can do this just don't spend any
unnecessary time there but i can try /
and roll out here we can save ourselves
some time we see try to do this play
this on especially at on time
yeah this is actually look better for
white but I won't go moon very ambitious
here brah I heard okay gain well let's
eight points every game is eight points
with the strategy so I'm taking the
eight points and I'm okay he never does
anything out of this routine he just
places stuff and if you are quick you
get a draw and eight points there's not
much to say about the game I'm just
playing along with this boring stuff and
get a draw what can you do let's just go
to the next game thanks for watching